[Music]
Katie Holmes and Jamie Foxx are still
going strong despite those recent
breakup reports this is according to a
source
the source tells eg that Katie might
even join Jamie for a pre fourth of July
vacation in Atlantic City this weekend
while daughter Suri is that summer camp
Jamie's already in AC making a surprise
appearance at the grand reopening of the
Ocean Resort Casino Jamie and Katie
haven't been spotted together for a
while but our source says that's pretty
standard quote they've always lived very
independent lives it's not uncommon for
them to go long stretches without seeing
each other adding they're still very
very private you're not going to hear or
see every time they're together because
they don't want the relationship in
public a rep for Katie also denied the
breakup rumors 2et calling the entire
story false the pair has always been
notoriously privates but did look
smitten at a pre Grammy bash in January
when eg asked Jamie about other photos
of him and Katie last year though we got
this you set the internet on fire with
those pictures what was that I know what
was this tell me the story behind any
white famous come see